[Applause]
yesterday the prime minister invoked the
emergencies act
24 hours in and there are more questions
than answers questions about whether
this is justified questions around if
the criteria is met questions around
what this means to canadians rights and
freedoms parliamentary approval is
required in order for the prime minister
to use this
unprecedented sledgehammer so can the
prime minister tell us
when will parliament be debating this
will it be coming to us on friday and
does he expect that we will look at it
friday but then rise take a week off and
not actually deal with this until march
the right honorable prime minister mr
speaker
after discussions with cabinet and
caucus after consultations with the
premiers of all provinces and
territories after a conversation with
opposition leaders
we decided to invoke the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades and
occupations i want to be very clear mr
speaker the scope of these measures are
time limited and geographically targeted
they are reasonable and proportionate to
the threats they're meant to address and
they are fully to be compliant with the
charter of rights and freedoms to
reassure all canadians that this is the
right thing to move forward
the honorable leader of the opposition i
had a very simple question to the prime
minister he was not able to answer it
would appear this could be more
political drama for the prime minister
he name calls people that he disagrees
with he wedges he divides he stigmatizes
yet in spite of all of his failure
coot's border has cleared
windsor has opened up provinces and
police are doing their jobs and
blockades are starting to come down but
the prime minister thinks that now is
the time to use this extreme measure and
invoke the emergencies act isn't it true
that the prime minister's actions could
serve to actually make things worse
and not make things better
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker this is about keeping
canadians safe protecting their
communities and neighborhoods and
ensuring jobs and our economy
i'm afraid i'm going to have to
interrupt the honorable the right
honourable prime minister i'm trying to
hear the answer and i'm having a very
difficult time there's some shouting
going on i'm going to have to ask the
honourable members maybe just keep it
down and if you've got something that
you're not agreeing with talk amongst
yourself with someone next to you you
don't have to shout it out to the person
across the floor
the right honourable prime minister
mr speaker you are absolutely right this
is a time for responsible leadership not
crass partisanship the situation
requires additional tools not held by
other federal provincial or territorial
law it's what responsible leadership
requires these measures must be and will
be compliant with the canadian charter
of rights and freedoms we will always
defend the rights of canadians to
peaceful assembly and to freedom of
expression but these blockades need to
end and unfortunately conservative
politicians continue to encourage the
leaders of these blockades
leader of the opposition well let's get
down to the basics of what this is
really about this is about the prime
minister's ideological attachment to
keeping covert restrictions and mandates
63 percent of canadians want the
restrictions and mandates to end
conservatives presented a motion
yesterday asking simply for a plan but
the prime minister is in denial and is
ignoring the science he might as well be
back at the cottage because he's doing
nothing productive or constructive to
help this situation
can the prime minister tell canadians
when he will end the divisive
outdated and unscientific mandate and
restrictions
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker like i said this is a time
for responsible leadership to end these
blockchains unfortunately the
conservatives continue to play partisan
games uh the conservative member of
provenche just yesterday i'm sorry i'm
going to have to cut off the prime
minister just for a second
and just
i mean heckling is usually throwing one
comment out clever hopefully although
not always necessary
but what i'm hearing is someone bullying
and trying to drown someone out that's
not
heckling i just want everyone to take a
deep breath and i'll let the prime
minister start from the top please
thank you mr speaker unfortunately we
see that even in a moment of extremely
challenging times when people are moving
forward with responsible leadership a
responsible tools the conservatives
can't help themselves but play class
crass political games and divide the
conservative member for provenche just
yesterday embraced the leaders of this
blockade and amplified their cause the
conservative member for yorkton melville
said this weekend the blockaders who
ripped down fencing around our national
war memorial are patriots the
conservative leadership contender from
carleton continues to say he's proud
[Applause]
is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
when
why does the prime
minister canadians
including his own member from louisiana
the honorable prime minister
speaker
and that's why we've had to take
responsible
provinces and stuff jurisdictions
supply chains and uh
legal demonstrations
in an emergency situation as we've seen
all over the country
and in many places
at the national assembly in quebec
is
does he really want is he looking for
support to impose legislation in quebec
against quebec
is
that we have come up with
it's proportionate and it's limited
and in its geographic applications
sadly we are in this crisis because
we've seen a failure to take this crisis
seriously at all levels of government
and now we're seeing indigenous and
racialized people look at the double
standard that the convoy is being
treated as compared to those protesters
we also have
deeply disturbing reports of military
and police personnel who've expressed
sympathy and support for the convoy
so will the prime minister provide
assurances in this house
that the police
will use the powers given to protect
people and not support the occupation
honorable prime minister
mr speaker the measured and responsible
use of the emergencies act that we
announced yesterday gives specific time
limited proportional tools to police of
local jurisdiction and their partners to
be able to ensure that these illegal
blockades end to make sure that people
who have now fully been heard by all
canadians
choose to go home these are the things
that canadians expect from their orders
of government and i can say that we have
worked extremely closely across orders
of government with all different
policies of jurisdiction to ensure that
canadians get their streets and their
lives back
for burnaby south
these emergency measures will not be
applied where they're not needed
emergencies
[Music]
anywhere where it's not needed these are
simply tools that local police
may or may not use it's up to them
it's a matter of ensuring that we have
all the tools
mr speaker the invocation of the
emergencies act for the first time in
canadian history is a damning indictment
on the failure of this prime minister to
address the situation the prime minister
once said i quote when a government asks
its citizens to give up even a small
portion of their liberty it is not
simply enough to say trust us that trust
must be earned it must be checked and it
must be renewed these are his words
canadians do not trust this prime
minister when will he stop undermining
canadians rights and start renewing
canadians
[Applause]
mr speaker
canadians can trust that this government
will always follow the science and the
best evidence to get us out of this
pandemic and that includes getting
vaccinated mr speaker and contrary to
what my colleague says this is an
illegal blockade this illegal blockade
is not about the vaccines or the
mandates it's about a very small
organized group who are trying to upend
our way of life mr speaker now we've
made progress we've seen the ambassador
bridge reopened we've seen coots reopen
we've seen surrey reopen and mr speaker
yesterday yes we invoke the emergencies
act so that we can secure that progress
and give law enforcement all the tools
they need thank you mr speaker the
honorable member for sturgeon river
parkland well we'll see if the prime
minister answers this one every
opportunity
in ottawa and around canada he has
chosen to hide to confront and to
escalate his divisive content conduct
has been a lesson in abject failure
blockades should come down they are
already coming down across this country
but now the prime minister has invoked
the emergencies act to punish canadians
who in his words hold unacceptable views
why is the prime minister punishing
canadians for their political views
the honorable government house leader
long ago that the former conservative
leader now the member for regina capell
with the conservative party said the
following these protesters these
activists may have the luxury of
spending days at a time at the block at
a blockade but they need to check their
privilege they need to check their
privilege and let the people whose jobs
depend on the railway system and small
business of farmers do their jobs and
what have they said now in this context
from the beginning as swastikas flew as
confederate flags flew they went out and
they gave coffee they took pictures they
have absolutely the opposite of
responsible leadership instead of
de-escalating they escalated at every
turn
[Music]
[Applause]
those emergencies
many provinces
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
invite the leader to listen
to
to
[Applause]
of people
[Music]
the
are you done now for two years the prime
minister has insisted he has making
decisions
i i just want to remind the honorable
members to place their questions through
the speaker
let her restart a little restarted
question
from the top again my apologies
for two years the prime minister has
insisted he is making decisions based on
science canadian sacrifice they isolated
closed businesses got vaccinated because
experts advised it was the safest way
forward now those same experts say it is
time to ease restrictions
premiers are listening but this prime
minister believes he knows better and
has invoked the emergency measures act
does the prime minister intend to force
provinces to implement measures they and
science disagree with
the honorable government
i'll tell you what i'm done with i'm
done with
seeing as this protest continues as the
legal actions continue that cost
billions of dollars to businesses that
terrorize downtown residents i am tired
of seeing conservative tweets such as
the member from vervanche who's saying
that he supports it the member for
yorkton melville saying that this
ripping down barricades in front of a
war memorial is a patriotic act watching
somebody who aspires to be leader of
conservative party saying that what's
happening outside is something he stands
by that is enough please it's time to
end this stop supporting what's going on
the honorable member for calgary
midnapore
mr speaker the rest of the world is
opening up and returning to normal where
the science supports it provinces are
providing canadians with hope for the
first time in two years contrary to this
prime minister whose lack of leadership
has brought him to invoke the emergency
measures act traumatizing canadians he
is well aware that many provinces are
opposed to these measures he is also
well aware that the science says that
they are not needed well this prime
minister forced provinces to implement
measures that they had independently
decided to remove
the honorable government
mr speaker canada has one of the lowest
death rates in the world one of the
highest vaccination rates in the world
it has met the challenge of this
pandemic but what has not been met in
this hour of history is that as the the
chaos descended outside as protesters
began to shut down critical
infrastructure we had lawmakers people
of this house
going out and encouraging their activity
and i have to ask mr speaker if they
didn't have lawmakers who were elected
by constituents encouraging their legal
actions when would have this been over i
think it would have been over a lot
sooner
[Applause]
it's really supposed to be the very last
resource the prime minister himself said
it's not the first tool we've used not
even
is
ambassador
in order to provide
did not get in touch with the people who
have besieged parliament for 19 days now
he didn't send his share of the 1800 law
enforcement officers requested by the
city of ottawa he didn't create a crisis
unit
including all governments and police
forces he didn't consult his partners in
quebec provinces before informing them
of his decision to invoke the
emergencies
[Applause]
is
uh
is
is
[Music]
[Applause]
um
mr speaker yesterday during a press
conference the prime minister said and i
quote
some people will say we move too quickly
other people will say no we should have
acted weeks ago
the reality is this
the emergencies act is not something to
take lightly it is not the first thing
you turn to nor the second nor the third
so my question is mr speaker can the
prime minister please tell canadians
what first
second and third actions he took before
invoking the emergency
and the disruptions that were taking
place in ottawa and then the blockades
and our critical infrastructure at our
ports of entry our government has worked
with municipal and provincial partners
right across the country in order to
ensure that they had the resources and
the support they needed to keep
canadians safe i'm sorry i'm going to
have to ask the minister to repeat i'm
right next to you to the honorable
member and i can't hear it because of
the shouting if i can ask the member of
the honourable minister to start from
the top so that at least i can hear it
and hopefully uh the honourable member
for peterborough kawartha can hear the
answer
for mr speaker i'm actually very glad to
see that the the conservatives have once
again changed their position on
something important whereas first they
supported these these these these
blockades and now that there's they
recognize that this is a largely
foreign-funded targeted and coordinating
attack on canadian critical
infrastructure they flip-flop good for
them we're all getting used to it
remember for peterborough
mr speaker i think the person or the
the party that is flip-flopped is the
liberals
last week you said you had all the tools
you needed
they needed to do this and now we have
an emergency measures act yeah we were
told we would never need federal vaccine
mandates that changed now you're saying
it's just jurisdiction how can we trust
this government how how much authority
does the prime minister need for to set
an unprecedented emergency measures act
how much authority does he need
the honorable minister
mr speaker the evidence the evidence is
clear
a largely foreign funded targeted and
coordinating attack on on critical
canadian infrastructure at our borders
is hurting canada and harming canadians
and mr speaker it was equally clear that
we needed to do more and we would have
to do what was required mr speaker we've
introduced measures that will create
greater financial scrutiny and financial
consequences for the people who are
engaged in this criminal behavior the
evidence of firearms at kutz elevates
the risk to canadian security and safety
and we will do what is required to keep
canadians safe
the honorable member for saskatoon west
mr speaker last friday the prime
minister said that the ottawa police had
enough resources to deal with the
protesters that's right and on monday he
calls for emergency measures
boy that escalated quickly
he had 17 days to act and after hiding
in his cottage on his macbook for the
first week he did nothing but divide and
stigmatize mr speaker the constituents
in saskatoon west want to know what
changed in the prime minister's mind
over the weekend to justify such drastic
measures
[Applause]
mr speaker i want to assure my colleague
that the rcmp has been supporting and
aiding the ottawa police service to
enforce public safety not only here in
ottawa but in windsor where we've
reopened the ambassador bridge in coots
where the borders reopened in surrey
where the borders reopened and that's
good it's good for the economy it's good
for canadians who can get back to work
mr speaker and yesterday's invocation of
the emergencies act is meant to secure
those gains so that we give the police
all the tools that that they need
whether it's declaring certain zones
which are adjacent to our borders to our
national symbols mr speaker it's
important for the conservatives to ask
those participating in the illegal
blockades to now go home
the honourable member for niagara falls
mr speaker for too long conservatives
have been calling on this government to
remove the mandatory pcr test
requirements for those entering canada
in my riding of niagara falls this
policy has had a devastating impact on
our economy visits from the u.s are
nowhere near the record levels reached
in 2019 and these expensive costs put on
our visitors and canadians traveling
prevent them from visiting
their families and loved ones my
residents want to know this when will
all federal travel mandates be ended
the honorable minister of transport
mr speaker i want to thank my honorable
colleague for giving me the opportunity
to share with him and all members of
this house and all canadians the great
announcement that myself and our
colleagues made today today based on the
science and the public health advice we
received we eased our travel measure
including mr speaker allowing incoming
travelers to use an antigen test instead
of the pcr pre-departure test thank you
very much mr speaker the honorable
member for windsor west
unlawful blockades at the borders across
the country including windsor and cootes
have been shown that the liberals have
not done the proper serious work
necessary to ensure that our borders are
protected and the citizens that live
nearby are safe
these illegal blockades have hurt every
canadian by hurting thousands of people
from getting to work and supporting
their families we have long been calling
for a safe border task force reinstate
cuts from the cbsa intelligence and also
to make sure that municipalities are
reinstated for their costs to the prime
minister will he finally listen to our
calls to ensure that safe borders are
going to happen or he's going to
continue to listen to extremists the
bridge might be open now but the threat
hasn't stopped will he act
the honorable minister
well mr speaker i share my honorable
colleagues concern and i can inform the
house that i've been in routine contact
with him as well as the municipal
leaders
in windsor including the mayor of
windsor and i've assured him and the
government will continue to provide all
of the resources that the community of
windsor needs to keep that bridge open
that means yes making sure that police
have the assets that they need be it tow
trucks be it barriers be whatever
resources so that we can keep the
economy rolling the bridge open and get
canadians back to work thank you mr
speaker the honourable member for
edmonton strathcona
and what about alberta you know mr
speaker yesterday the rcmp arrested 13
extremists blockading the border at
cootes they seized guns ammunition and
body armor including assault weapons
with thousands of rounds this comes
after convoy leaders raised millions
from foreign donors with a stated goal
to overthrow the government and while
i'm happy to see that the blockade
appears to be ending in alberta the fact
remains that we had an armed militia
active in alberta this is unthinkable
why did it take 18 days and proof of an
armed threat to make the government act
and protect albertans and canadians
gold minister for emergency preparedness
mr speaker i i thank the member for that
very important question and and i think
it does reveal and we agree
that what we have seen in in in in kutz
alberta and in a number of these
blockades illegal blockades across the
country is the threat is not yet gone
and that's precisely why mr speaker
we've introduced through these measures
of the emergency measures the emergency
act that we introduced yesterday that
will increase for example the financial
scrutiny and consequences of these
illegal acts that will also make
available equipment and authorities that
our law enforcement officials need to
maintain and restore public safety and
to protect canada's interest well member
for davenport mr speaker since the
government of canada announced its
ambitious plan for a 10 a day early
learning and child care system across
the country we have signed agreements
with nine provinces in three territories
already in some provinces families are
seeing a reduction in their child care
fees making life more affordable but
those in my riding of davenport in
downtown west toronto are wondering when
is ontario going to sign on and when
will they too be able to benefit from
our national child care program can the
here any updates on the federal
government's efforts to reach a child
care agreement with ontario
the honorable minister
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank my honorable colleague from
davenport for that important question we
have now signed agreements with 12
provinces and territories across the
country
that means that families from coast to
coast to coast except for in ontario at
this point in time will have access to
50 percent reduction in fees by the end
of this calendar year mr speaker i
remain very optimistic that we will sign
an agreement with ontario there is a
fair deal on the table 10.2 billion
dollars that will go to helping families
decrease the cost of child care and make
life more affordable member for
evansville
well canadians are stressed paychecks
don't buy what they used to in fact the
cost of everything gasoline
groceries housing
is at all time highs families are
getting left behind so last april i
wrote to the minister to warner of
exactly that i highlighted the dangers
of uncontrolled borrowing and how
excessive stimulus spending would stoke
inflationary pressures she either
doesn't care or didn't read my letter so
to the minister what specifically is she
doing to get inflation under control
the honorable deputy prime minister
mr speaker the conservatives continue
actually in all aspects of canadian life
to put forward a false narrative and the
latest false narrative we've just been
hearing today is about the economy the
reality is that the canadian economy is
recovering strongly from the coveid
recession
in the third quarter our gdp grew by 5.4
that is higher than the us japan the uk
and australia and you know what mr
speaker when it comes to our debt to gdp
ratio our aaa credit rating was
reaffirmed in the fall by s p and
moody's
the honourable member for rabbitsford
well we will never get inflation under
control as long as that minister keeps
borrowing and spending like there's no
tomorrow not only did the minister
ignore our concerns she also ignored the
warnings of the parliamentary budget
officer who questioned the wisdom of her
stimulus spending pumping more money
into the economy when the cost of living
is skyrocketing this minister is making
this crisis worse
this problem is not transitory months by
month the inflation numbers are going up
when will the minister finally do
something to protect canadians against
the skyrocketing costs of living
the right to the honorable deputy prime
minister
you know mr speaker the real question is
when will the conservatives stick with a
policy or stick with a leader
because i was on the campaign trail in
the summer and so were the members
opposite
and they actually campaigned on proposed
government spending higher than our own
proposal
we proposed a deficit for 2122
of
156.9 billion dollars they campaigned on
a proposed deficit of 168 billion
so i wonder if the party of flip-flops
can tell canadians where they stand
today
the honorable member for kelowna lake
country thank you mr speaker the excise
escalator tax increase will crush
wineries breweries cideries and
distilleries bottom line the excise
escalator tax is automatic and here's
the kicker it's based on the cpi index
meaning because inflation is so high the
tax will be even higher than ever before
starting april 1st
this tax is based on inflation
it's taxing inflation which will make
inflation go up even more on these
important value-added agricultural
products so will the liberals commit to
cancel this inflationary excise tax
increase
the honorable deputy prime minister
you know mr speaker it is a bit rich of
the conservatives to be talking about
supporting small businesses of any kind
in this country after all mr speaker
this is the party which when we before
christmas proposed absolutely essential
support for small business to help them
get through omicron what did the
conservatives do at that crucial moment
they voted against our measures so
really mr speaker we will take no
lessons about supporting business from
them
the honourable member for kelowna lake
country well thank you mr speaker that
wasn't an answer to my question at all
when canadian winery brewery cidering
distillery workers wake up and owners on
april 1st they'll be hit with this
automatic tax increase on excise thanks
to the liberals 95 of these producers
are small businesses who have already
been hit with payroll tax increases
labor shortages increases in debt and
slower sales due to perpetual lockdowns
now is not the time to be increasing any
taxes on small businesses so will the
liberals cancel this bad april fool's
day tax increase
[Applause]
mr speaker let me tell you what hurts
canadian small businesses
what hurts canadian small businesses is
when
for
solely for the sake of parties and
posturing people who were elected to
this house to support the small
businesses in their communities oppose
the small business support that small
businesses themselves are calling for
and you know what else has hurt canadian
businesses small ones and big ones too
the blockade of the ambassador bridge
and members on that side of the house
were giving supper and encouragement to
those blockades that is unacceptable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
is
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
mr speaker for weeks canadians looking
for hope have been looking for a prime
minister to listen to their concerns and
listen to their needs as the rest of the
world opened up instead they heard from
a prime minister with an escalating tone
that left them feeling traumatized
stigmatized and divided even today he's
calling out and blaming other parties
who have been listening instead of
pitting canadian versus canadian and
showing real leadership why do canadians
have to pay with their freedoms to cover
up for this government's failed
leadership
[Applause]
mr speaker i think we have different
definitions of division to me when
critical infrastructure is being blocked
when illegal protesters are outside when
we see swastikas and confederate flags
going out and taking photographs of
giving coffee i don't think that's
healthy for the country mr speaker
instead what i think would be healthy to
is to say to those that would seek to
divide us those that would seek to
exploit our differences to say those
kinds of radical views do not have a
place in this country it's time to go
home it's time to end this illegal
activity and it's time to come together
as a country
the honourable member for dolphins swan
river nipah mr speaker i sent out a
survey last month asking my constituents
what was their biggest concerns
the cost of living was the number one
issue
one of my constituents named rick wrote
to me and stated the food prices are out
of my pay range mr speaker inflation is
record at record highs due to this
liberal government spending
so what does the prime minister have to
say to rick who can't afford to put food
on his table here good question
prime minister
speaker our government absolutely
understands that affordability matters
for canadian families and that's why we
are there for them we lowered taxes for
the middle class and raised them on the
wealthiest one percent we created the
canada child benefit which is indexed to
inflation and now a single mother with
two children can receive up to thirteen
thousand six hundred dollars from the
ccb
the climate action incentive gives the
average family in alberta 981 dollars in
saskatchewan 961 dollars mr speaker the
honourable member for simcoe north
mr speaker at the beginning of covet all
the parties came together to support
relief programs for canadians and
businesses
now the economy is opening up but the
government's money printing press is
still humming
experts are now warning this government
what members of this side of the house
have been warning for some time that
this government's future spending plan
will lead to more inflation mr speaker
let's give the minister one last chance
when will this government reign in it's
out of control
the honorable deputy prime minister
[Music]
mr speaker
as i pointed out a moment ago it is
actually the members opposite the
members of the party of flip-flops who
campaigned on a platform which proposed
higher spending
in this fiscal year than we proposed so
let's remind canadians of that and in
fact mr speaker when it comes to
supporting small business it was this
party contrary to what the member just
asserted that opposed the essential
support small businesses needed that we
proposed before christmas
the honorable member for vancouver
granville michele
have an advantage
language
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
today more fishermen have been lost at
sea and our hearts go out to them
captains know the risk of sinking while
fishing
what adam newell wasn't counting on was
losing his vessel while tied up at a dfo
wharf
adam saw his vessel smash into the rocks
tied to that wharf
dfo wharfs are falling into the ocean
adam monado lost his vessel if the
government had not ignored
four fishery committee reports of this
house
when will the government act so more
vessels are not lost tied up with the
wharf without dwarfs we can't fish
the honourable minister for fisheries
speaker
90
of canadian seafood goes through small
craft harbors and canada's fish
harvesters depend on these facilities to
support their livelihoods and so that's
why in budget 2021 we allocated 300
million dollars
to repair and replace
these wars over the next two years we're
working to make sure that the
communities have the harbors that they
need and that they're in good repairs
[Applause]
[Music]
never-ending delays
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
mr speaker on friday i asked this
government if it was their intent to
place public health policy in direct
conflict with immigration legislation
once their working permits expire after
february 28th some guest workers are
trapped in canada without status
separated from their family separated
from work the minister of immigration
response made it clear that this
government had no apparent idea of this
policy conflict
when will this liberal government treat
innocent people fairly humanely and
respect them and fix this liberal fiasco
the honorable minister
[Applause]
i think that the member for his question
and as always our commitment
in
modernizing our immigration system
is relevant i was very happy to see that
our government invested 85 million
dollars in improving our immigration
system and mr speaker we are more than
happy that to say to you
as we talk about some of the success of
2021 that we welcome more than 405 000
new permanent residents last year we are
welcoming more skilled workers and
international students
you know mr speaker we need to do better
and we're continuing to do for northwest
territories
mr speaker i'm glad your principles in
part recognize that there's over
representation of indigenous people in
the criminal justice system and that
there are complex issues based on
systemic discrimination which should be
considered in sentencing
they now have been used in courts and
sentencing for quite some time
however in the final report of the
national inquiry on murdered and missing
indigenous women and girls
[Music]
i'm sorry this is something that comes
up often and i understand there has been
some accommodation made i'm going to
have to talk with our technical folks so
that we can make it so that
the honourable member
i'm going to ask the honorable
excuse me excuse me you can interrupt
each other but when you interrupt the
speaker you don't want to get them upset
the honorable member for northwest
territories does he have a headset there
that he can use i'll come back to him
for a question just for the microphone i
understand there's some problems with
the hearing but with the microphone that
would be the only way to get the
interpretation otherwise we're going to
miss half the question and that's not
really good for anyone not for the
member nor for those here
i'm sorry but we're not getting
interpretation on that microphone it's a
technical issue
we'll uh
what i'll do is i'll go to the next
question and maybe we'll see if we can
get that result for the next one
the honourable member for vancouver east
major general fraser said canada pulled
out of afghanistan way too early and 10
000 afghan interpreters and their
families have been left behind he also
said the liberals failed to provide a
whole of government plan to help
resettle them while our allies are on
the ground helping afghans get to safety
this government is sending emails to
telling afghans to somehow get to a
third country on their own as the
situation gets worse this government
still hasn't provided exemptions so ngos
can get aid to starving children when
will the liberals act with the urgency
that the situation demands to help bring
afghans to safety
the honorable minister
mr speaker canada remains firm in its
commitment to welcome 40 000 afghan
refugees in canada we are sparing no
efforts to resettle afghan refugees as
quickly as we can and i am happy to
report that more than 5 7
500 afghan refugees have begun their new
lives here in canada over welcome over
overcoming extreme challenges and we are
welcoming new arrival every week we'll
continue to do everything we can to show
leadership in the face of the
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan
a member for timmins of timmins james
bay
well when it comes to assessing the
prime minister's credibility on the
climate crisis the truth is found in the
lobbying registry because over the last
two years his government rolled up the
red carpet for big oil with over 370
meetings no wonder big oil isn't
sweating his promise of a tough
emissions cap in fact they told our
committee they plan to vastly increase
production and that position is backed
by the energy regulator so to the
environment minister what kind of
credible cap is there that includes
massive increases in oil exports
the honorable minister for natural
resources
thank you very much mr speaker i thank
my honorable colleague for his question
and i've i've asked him that before and
he still hasn't answered but i would
like him to show me a country in the
world that has done more in the last
four or five years than we have to fight
climate change more than 100 measures
100 billion dollars of investment
regulations on methane clean fuel
standards electricity these are all
things we're doing and we have so much
more to do mr speaker thank you very
much
mr speaker the gladu principles in part
recognize that there is an
over-representation of indigenous people
in the criminal justice system and that
here are complex issues based on
systemic discrimination which should be
considered in sentencing they now have
to be used in courts and sentencing for
quite some times however in the final
report of the national inquiry of
murdered and missing indigenous women
and girls many participants expressed
concerns about overlining sentences in
cases of violence against indigenous
women and girls does the minister of
justice have an answer to those worried
about the gladiu principles negatively
impacting the safety and justice for
indigenous women and girls
honorable minister of justice
thank the honorable member for asking
that question instead of the honorable
member from the northwest territories
and i thank him for his leadership and
his wisdom mr speaker the gladdu
principles just like the revitalization
of indigenous justice systems calls to
action from the trc the implementation
plan for the mmiwg
are concrete steps towards making our
justice system fairer but we understand
mr speaker there are still systemic
issues in our criminal justice system
that we need to address it's impossible
to undo centuries of colonialism in only
a few short years mr speaker far too
many women and girls endure serious
injustice including discrimination and
disproportionately high rates of
violence we're going to work on this
with indigenous leadership mr speaker
together
i'm afraid that's all the time we have
for today
rising on a point of order i believe the
honourable member for south shore saint
margaret's point of order mr speaker uh
arising out of question period i'd like
to seek unanimous consent
to table
the four
house of commons fishery committee
reports that this liberal government has
not responded to on small
[Applause]